only et was on set with the ladies of
the real for Real Housewives of Atlanta
takeover week
how'd Cynthia do today amazing and after
the episode the co-hosts got candid
about the tough topics they tackled it
so far season three you guys have been
delving into some pretty tough topics
getting very real because it's an
election here why is that important to
you guys to talk about on the show
because we want to voice that it's so
essential for people to vote if you
really don't like what you see out there
then you have the chance of changing
it's very important for you to really
find topics policies issues that are
really important to you and vote vote
based on that don't not vote even if I
tell you who I'm voting for you
shouldn't just vote for that person
because I said so to get out there
educate yourself be knowledgeable about
why I'm voting for that and maybe why
you should or why should not in Adrienne
you made some headlines with the sexual
harassment sexual assault talk that was
recently on the show I even experienced
an executive that would kiss me on the
lips like if he saw me going through the
hallways it would be like huh
consistently happened to the point where
I was like this ain't cool man like now
he knows I'm not gonna say anything
right which is not okay why was that an
important topic for you to bring up on
the show um honestly I hope that it just
encourage other people to have an open
platform about talking about these
things that women shouldn't feel ashamed
about the things that they've
experienced and that right is right and
wrong is wrong and you should speak up
about it and I just hope that me saying
it saying hey this is something that we
go through that people go through I go
through it you go through it and then it
can make somebody feel comfortable
enough to voice that's the nice thing
about our show we take what's happening
in this country and then we can use it
as a jump-off point and now we're
pulling out stories that you know we
didn't even know about yeah is there any
topic that is off-limits for you guys
you won't touch on the show no no
everything's pretty friend gay